Russian police arrested more than 1300
people protest protesting the
mobilization of reservists to fight in
Ukraine President Putin says he is
calling up 300 000 reservists to bolster
his forces there western leaders say his
call-up is a response to Russian losses
on the battlefield in a conflict that's
been raging much longer than expected
Vladimir Putin's latest decree is not
going unchallenged in Russia
but the state's Crackdown is hard
nonetheless
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this monitoring group says Mass arrests
have been made across the country
including in Moscow
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid of
anything the most valuable thing that
they can take from us is the lives of
our children I won't give them my
child's life
Putin has called the mobilization
necessary and urgent
he accused the west of crossing a line
by providing sophisticated weapons to
Ukraine
I'd like to remind you that our country
also has various weapons of Destruction
and in certain aspects even more modern
weapons than NATO countries if there's a
threat to the territorial Integrity of
our country in order to protect Russia
and our people we will certainly use all
the means at our disposal this is not a
bluff
the announcement has also triggered an
apparent Exodus of people unwilling to
join the conflict
many of these Russians arriving in
Serbia are still fearful of speaking in
opposition to the war
it because my government and police can
see it and I will have problem in my
country but but I want to say
freedom for Ukraine I I want to please
somebody stop putting
the prices are one-way flights from
Russia has been skyrocketing since
Putin's speech
and they're still selling out fast
with more on this let's speak to our
Moscow bureau chief Yuri rashetto he's
based in regalatvia now after DW was
forced to leave Russia hiori good to see
you so what are you hearing today about
The Descent in Russia after President
Putin's call-up of reservists
the distance seems to be widespread
across Russia and people are absolutely
nervous it's said that partial
mobilization will affect 3000 300 000
preservists which is supposed to be just
one point one percent of the total
number of those who can be called up but
the problem is that most in Russia do
not believe in partial mobilization and
think that much more men will be called
up than announced some are trying to
leave the country we just saw it in the
report uh plane tickets have skyrocketed
others go to an advocate the third will
probably try to get fake certificates
about any illness in order not to be
called up I've got many friends in
Russia who are now living in great fear
even though they have never served in
the army
Yuri how is State media treating the
call up and how does their coverage of
Putin move public opinion
well of course the Russian State media
leave no doubt that the mobilization in
Russia is right and necessary uh it's no
wonder they absolutely aligned uh
Warriors about dying at the front are
overshadowed by other specific Warriors
such as what shall I do with my mortgage
if I am called up and my employer
officials officially fires me or will
the reservists be treated financially in
the same way in the same way as the
professional soldiers of course all of
this distracts from the real question
will I survive at all or will I have to
die at the front like thousands or of
other Russian soldiers in recent months
but these questions have been not asked
on Russian television so far but on the
streets where yesterday thousands of
people protested
so you're we're seeing dissent we've
seen arrests we've even seen booked out
flights on which many Russians seem to
be fleeing the country is it likely that
that there'll be any tangible impact on
Putin or the conduct of the war in
Ukraine as a result of all this
it's Pablo difficult to say if and how
many Russians are going to take to the
streets in the next days some experts
say that this mobilization is at the
beginning of the end of Putin's career
because the mood in the country can
change completely others on the other
hand don't see any Mass protests coming
because people are totally intimidated I
think that the Russians are just totally
disoriented disoriented the war that
seemed far away somewhere beyond the
borders is now suddenly in their own
country and many who didn't want to know
anything about this so-called Special
Operation and many are now directly
confronted with the war as for Putin's
plans in Ukraine I think that with this
mobilization has clearly shown that he
has no intention of changing his plans
of ending this war on the contrary he is
obviously preparing the Russians the
Russian people for a long War
thank you Yuri DW's Yuri rashetto in the
Latvian Capital Riga thank you
now to some other stories making
headlines around the world
European Union foreign policy Chief
Joseph Burrell says the EU will impose
more sanctions on Russia spoke after an
emergency meeting of EU foreign
ministers on the sidelines of the un's
general assembly the decision comes in
response to the kremlin's order to
mobilize Reserve troops for the war in
Ukraine
foreign
lithuania's government says it will
assess every visa application by Russian
citizens seeking to avoid military
service there are already exceptions for
Russians on humanitarian grounds earlier
neighboring Latvia said it will not
issue visas to Russians avoiding
mobilization
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has implored the world to punish Russia
for its invasion of his country in a
much anticipated video address on day
two of the United Nations General
Assembly he also laid out five
conditions for peace with Russia
the second day of the United Nations
General Assembly a conference dominated
by Challengers and crises
Global Food shortages soaring Energy
prices the dangers of climate change
all overshadowed by the war in Ukraine
in a rare video address President
Vladimir zielinski laid out what he
called the Ukrainian peace formula five
non-negotiable conditions to end the
conflict
between different all five items of our
formula punishment for aggression
protection of Life restoration of
security and territorial Integrity
security guarantees and determination to
defend
oneself I rule out that the settlement
can happen on a different basis than the
Ukrainian peace formula
but as Ukraine outlined conditions for
peace Russia prepared for escalation
just hours before the general assembly
gathered Russian President Vladimir
Putin announced a partial mobilization
of military reservists
in his own pre-recorded address to the
nation he also made veiled threats to
defend Russia using nuclear weapons
U.S President Joe Biden condemned
Putin's threats as Reckless and called
on world leaders to stand against Russia
and uphold the principles of the United
Nations because if Nations can pursue
their Imperial Ambitions without
consequences
then we put at risk everything is very
institution stands for everything
but despite widespread condemnation in
the general assembly there is little the
UN can do in Practical terms
as one of five permanent members of the
security Council Russia holds the power
to veto any binding resolutions
for more let's speak to Dr Jade McGlynn
a Russia expert and author who's joining
us from the English city of Oxford
welcome to DW so in a speech Vladimir
Putin threatened to use nuclear weapons
and said quote it's not a bluff how
seriously do you take this threat
well I think we have to take it a little
bit seriously considering that we are
talking about the possibility of nuclear
Annihilation which is a very Hefty topic
indeed to be talking about um quite
early in the morning at least in
European time
um that said he does tend to resort to
nuclear blackmail when
um Russia is suffering defeat or is not
doing well in the war and the use of
nuclear rhetoric has been a
long-standing feature of Putin's
presidencies particularly since 2012 and
because their nuclear their nuclear
stockpile is one of the remaining ways
in which Russia is is quite clearly
still a superpower and perhaps
especially at a time when the military
is not doing as well as as they might
hope it's it's a useful Boon for for the
ego
right well yesterday you tweeted that
Russians marching and fleeing now aren't
protesting the killing of ukrainians
they're protesting that they'll have to
kill ukrainians or be killed by them so
could this motivate enough Russians to
stand up to Putin's War
yes I think as a clarification of course
some Russians are protesting both I
think it's more what I mean is the act
is different the act of mobilization is
not the sorry the act of protesting
mobilization is not the same as the act
of protesting a war against ukrainians
um when it doesn't involve you directly
I do think that this is potentially
quite a dangerous
um situation because
ultimately the Russian government relies
on removing political agency from people
and so if part of your entire kind of Mo
modus operandi is to remove political
agency from people and expect them to
just sort of accept things and to stay
out of politics then if if you give them
political agency one you they might not
like it and they might protest it even
if they're not necessarily against the
war or two they might like it very much
and they might really get a taste for
this political agency and who knows what
they might do with that
do you see a way that President Putin
could ever accept the conditions to end
the conflict laid out by president
voladamir zelanski
very apologies
um no not really I don't see any
situation and I think as well even it's
very
difficulty talks about
um trials for example but I don't see of
war crimes but really that's that seems
quite unlikely what I do think is good
is that it helps to kind of broaden the
Overton window of what the West might
see as acceptable
um and of course of a lot of misleans he
has every right to ask for those things
and I think really everybody would like
to see that one everybody but most
people who are supportive of Ukraine
would like to see such trials but
they're just not realistic without
either the total defeat of Russia which
for the reasons we discussed I.E Russia
is a nuclear superpower is not possible
or with Russia's agreement which I think
seems very unlikely because this isn't
just about defeating Putin but there's
an entire mindset that resonates with
Putin and is why Russians um not support
but perhaps have acquiesce to the war at
least until now
Dr Jade McGlynn in the English city of
Oxford thank you
thank you